I was stone cold sober but Nikki was
drunk and I couldn't die
okay that helped a lot Vicodin
[Music]
all right check this out uh this is a
video of something that happened at a
New Year's Eve party in New York
um in the middle of this big party uh
this random I don't know how random they
are didn't seem like a lot of people
knew them but
a guy started a proposal to his girl oh
I saw that I thought this happened in
Hawaii oh you said New York is it white
oh this is New York up there it said New
Year's up there just kidding
New Year's Eve it happened it's a New
Year's Eve party Not NYC no it does New
Year's Eve in NYC oh I don't know why it
says NY at the end but it is Hawaii
maybe it's in New York Hawaii
on the island of New York yeah yeah it's
in the Bronx Waikiki yeah also New York
Post posted it so it could be yeah I
think it's I was thinking about New Year
a rooftop venue in Hawaii yeah so here's
um
it's a little awkward but let me just
show it to you guys first
life oh no
[Music]
oh no
she's like yelling at him right now
she's like you [__]
you hear that what'd you say he goes
it's a simple yes or no
so she said yes with a question mark
which is kind of weird
and why was she thinking so long yeah
she takes a long time to answer he ends
up going it's a simple yes or no and she
goes yes and then moments later a guy
could ever say here they are assemble
yes or no
here here's the uh there's a moments
later moments later
moments later they're on the side and
they're arguing
uh why did you do this to me yeah
there's is someone just recording it
um I like how they're just
so
public proposals are rough though how do
we feel about
public proposal it's on her too it's on
both of them right is it I think it's on
both of them crazy how come well it's
like sometimes it's on the guide to no
a little bit about what your lady is
yeah it's definitely on the guide to
know if it what the answer should
already be yeah and then the setting too
yeah and the but then the girl also gets
a ton of the spotlight what did it say
in captions when they're fighting
afterwards I just was saying like um
they immediately started fighting
afterward oh so I did a fairly public
proposal but like in my situation for
over a year I already knew exactly what
ring she wanted we discussed different
things it's not the guy guys should know
yeah 100 like I would not have done that
in front of even my only and my public
proposal was in front of my like closest
friends and peers in my community and
her family and stuff like that right you
gotta remember I had to know like 10
times I had to call her best friends I
had to call her sisters like it takes a
lot I had to sit down with her mom and
dad and ask for her there was a lot of
planning right yeah there was like 12
steps okay this is my probably my
favorite public proposal video of all
time this one's real of all time is real
oh
that way
[Laughter]
no okay yeah oh you know that would be
uh well she had to say yeah she looked
at the camera
oh she Whispers in his ears
he's like I just met you yesterday
oh wait for it wait for it watch the
mascot
the mascot wait for it wait for it
oh oh she's dipping the [__] out of this
dipping she's like oh [__]
Tracy McGrady he's laughing
that's a wild thing to happen and go
back to that basketball game
hahaha
I love the character oh man the mask
that's rough bro
but someone to own this is on the guy
bro there's another angle if you were
the mascots like as she's walking away
he's like
it's so relaxing you know what that you
know what okay my this is where my brain
immediately goes my brain goes to
he feels that it's Rocky and he's trying
to either one lock it in or he doesn't
know her even like that yeah but he's
trying to lock it in either way he's
trying to unlock it the [__] in because
he's afraid of losing the grip that's
why I think it's always on the guy yeah
you already know he's prematurely doing
it because he's just trying to lock it
in because he's afraid of losing
something because he probably knows that
he doesn't have her oh it's also weird
when it's like like with Anthony's
proposal that is probably the perfect
version of that because it's almost like
everything around is tailored for that
moment versus when you go to a public
thing and then you tell like you tell
the person hey uh I'm gonna propose my
girl can you announce it and then no one
knows you yeah and you're just like in
the moment is this random people yeah
and some women have like an ideal way
they want to get proposed to like some
people just don't want to be in the
spotlight around yeah
I [__] blame the movies dude that we
grew up
dude remember 10 Things I Hate About You
this guy's like serenading this [__]
and all this stuff holy [__] watch your
members that we said why does that I was
like she was dying of cancer yeah I
didn't say that but Anthony you got you
got Nina's permission to like do a
public thing or like how did that work
uh it wasn't so much um it wasn't like
Public public it was actually Ryan was
there too um and it was that yeah but we
weren't there yeah it wasn't funny yeah
so that sucks sorry continue to start I
was technically working so it's a little
different I mean I hadn't met you yet
but still yeah I didn't know you either
but I knew him but he didn't invite me
it was coveted time so I was only
inviting my friends
we were closing the studio so we did a
last minute showcase uh and it was
honestly the the energy it was crazy
I'll talk about this the energy during
that time was actually really somber
because like we had
yeah it was just super like a sad and
depressing thing everyone's trying to
like prep like moving out the furniture
like liquidating stuff selling this like
you know all of our hopes and dreams
that we put in this place so recently
you know like the the energy is really
weird but at the same time
um it was that time where I was thinking
about proposing anyway or I knew I was
in that space in my relationship and
then I was like well we got to do this
last minute showcase uh as the last
hoorah for this place and I was like
everybody's gonna be there everyone
important is going to be there I was
like holy [__] this is the only time I'm
gonna have everybody in like one spot
for something so I was like oh snap so
that was what triggered like the
possibility of it but again I had for
over a year a PDF of all of like Nita's
wishes for like the type of ring and
like all the specification like we had
talked about many times you know what I
mean and then knowing like a month
beforehand of this showcase that we were
gonna have a very select amount of
people because again during covid like
that we're gonna be there I still was
like okay I have to go ask her parents I
have to go see if her family's in town
because if they're not there it doesn't
matter like why would I propose in front
of just my friends and not hurt it's
about her yeah and obviously my friends
are her friends too but like if her
family's not there and that means the
most if her best friends aren't there
it's like what am I doing it for am I
really just doing it for me but then
because everyone was available I was
like okay I have to do it did she like
was she able to suspect anything was
gonna happen like why is all my family I
[__] up as usual I I [__] up because
here's the thing like everything was
like turn Zoom meetings right there's no
in-person stuff so as we're preparing
the Showcase and I'm like you know
obviously one of the leaders of this
kind of thing so I'm like directing this
I'm like figuring out all the planning
for the Showcase I'm in a zoom and this
is when I was living in downtown L.A at
one of my apartments that didn't have
um you remember this too like my my
office was really the laundry room and
literally the laundry machine is right
here there's no door to it so in a one
studio apartment flat type thing that
has no door on the room and you're it's
in downtown it's like if you talk here
it doesn't matter if she's in the
bedroom you can't hear us and we'd be
Skyping and then Nina just comes to the
bathrooms loading laundry yeah it's a
really really low-key kind of humble
office of mine right and we're on the
zoom meeting talking about the [__]
showcase and stuff and then I just said
something about the last act which was
my proposal and I knew right when I said
it I like [__] just wide-eyed and
everybody on the screen was like and
Nino's in the living room oh
heard it she did she for sure did you
ever ask her I asked her afterwards yeah
I said afterwards and she already knew
yeah after I performed what a [__]
[__] I was so [__] nosy
watch TV with headphones
pretend there's a door here she just
knew something was gonna happen that
night oh okay but she had no idea what
happened there's still no way that like
dude you can't hide from these [__]
oh yeah I hate these [__] but at
least at least you she was prepped to
probably look good for that day she was
because she didn't she wouldn't come in
all bummed out and she was like [__]
women are so [__] observant but
then they're so good at keeping it
secret they're like God damn it like
when I proposed to Nikki he was in
Hawaii and like Nikki totally told her
mom that she thought I was proposing I
only told her dad by the way because I
asked for his permission pre of course
which by the way was a pimp move my my
father told me not to do that really
right it would have been a huge mistake
he's like he's like well if he says no
Then you gotta go buy that and I was
like no if he says no I want to know
what the [__] going on so I can fix it
um right like why don't you like me
[__] let's fix this [__] right
and then he is a [__] I'm more
of a confrontational person my father's
not my father's a better man than I'll
ever be can't do much about it right but
I was like okay I'm gonna propose to
Nikki and Hawaii that's gonna be sick
I guess they were staying in a hotel and
I put on this like sunscreen that as
soon as you get in the water it like
comes off of you like as soon as you're
in it wasn't like water safe or whatever
so by the time it's like eight o'clock
and we're going to dinner I'm a [__]
Red Lobster dude I'm so burned that I
could barely move my [__] arms like
I'm like oh God and like you know how
when you're sunburned like if you feel
your own shirt it's like radiating heat
like a microwave
it was so bad it's like little needles
the cotton feels like needles yeah but
then I had this resin that I booked like
[__] month before and I was like
getting this done with the rezzy right
but then I just watched the Colts lose
and I was like this could be a bad Omen
you know what I mean but that so then
I'm so nervous I'm [__] [__] the
whole time and also my dad told me not
to bring the ring because like it's
worth a lot of money and then like maybe
it'll get like if I'm like bringing it
in like somebody will [__] with it at
the airport and I'm like whatever old
man I'm literally not listening to you
I'm I brought it in snuck it in have
like a bulge in my shirt like this the
ring
[Music]
I'm a [__] idiot right so so by the
time I'm actually proposing I'm like
[__] shaking and [__] and then you
know Nikki starts crying I start crying
while I'm proposing her and [__] and
she's like and then yes afterwards I'm
like we should tell our family and [__]
and she's like
she's like yeah I already told my mom
you're gonna do it and I
know my dad told her and she's like
she's like
permission but no
um I just knew I just [__] knew and I
was like did you find the ring and she's
like no I didn't know where the ring I
didn't know you had a ring at all but I
knew you were gonna do it
and I told she told like half of her
family that I was doing yeah yeah these
[__] are [__] crazy they're crazy
you know how crazy they are so I had
this PDF that I mentioned like six
minutes ago right about this [__]
ring I've had this for like a year two
weeks before I'm about to [__]
propose she's like actually I want this
type of diamond oh and in my mind I was
like I don't give a [__] like I already
got this yeah I've been sitting on the
street for like four months I want
princess coming around like a high
conflict Diamond
hey you know what is crazy though I will
say like being an observer of how you
executed that [__] perfect yeah
because like we're all there thinking
we're gonna see a dance showcase changes
are performing suddenly it starts to
become more of an Anthony solo the music
gets softer the lights feel more magical
everyone went to the bathroom during
that time no it was like perfect the
good thing Nick wasn't there you guys
have seen Nick watch King's videos
you could really feel like the
atmosphere is Shifting and everyone's
like you start hearing the whole crowd
going like what like they start to
figure it out and then everyone goes
like this and we look to the second
floor behind the glass her whole family
lined up that we didn't even know it was
here that's a baller this guy puts on
million dollar shows
like a nutcracker Soldier and then he's
just like gets down and everyone's like
dude thanks Anthony yeah everyone's
creaming their panties I was I was
really drunk by this point though that's
a baller move and I I probably should
not have drank them why did you drink so
much I was nervous dude it was it was
like perfect execution yeah I was just
nervous and then I was just like I I
look back on that video and I'm like I
should have probably taken three less
shots and just said like straight to the
point I was stone cold sober but Nikki
was drunk and I drugged her okay
that helped a lot Vicodin
[Music]
thank you
foreign